Opposers, I love this country.
It's where I was born,
it's where I do this show,
and it is definitely
where I will die--
unless my space laser tag park
idea gets off the ground.
-(laughter)
-Sadly, these days,
I'm seeing this country change.
And not in the good ways-- like
when a forest becomes a Walmart.
-(laughter)
-No. Sometimes...
when I look around, I don't
recognize my country anymore.
-♪ ♪
-(whooping, applause)
First up: The family.
From getting married
to raising children,
today's American family
resembles
more of a Canadian's
legal marijuana fever dream
than the traditional unit
we know and love.
Just look at what's
happening to marriage.
NEWSWOMAN: Take a look at this.
These dermal wedding piercings
are what's hot right now
for newlyweds.
You can see here--
there's no ring.
The diamonds are
actually connected to a base
that's pierced under the skin.
-(audience groaning)
-What?! What?!
Getting the diamond implanted
into your hand
like you're living in
Elizabeth Taylor's police state?
(laughter)
Not on my watch...
which is above the skin,
by the way.
I mean, look at that ring.
That's got to hurt.
The ring isn't supposed
to be the painful part.
-That's the wedding night.
-(laughter)
There is so much blood.
I lost almost a pint.
(laughter)
Look... American matrimony
is about two things--
the permanent bond of marriage
and the freedom
to break that permanent bond.
And then create a new permanent
bond for a little while.
And then break that bond
and then create
yet another permanent bond
with a Slovenian model,
and then temporarily
remove that bond
when you meet a porn star
at a golf tournament.
Which, to be clear,
is not what happened.
But surgically implanted
diamonds?
Is that how we do it now?
Is this even America?
Maybe it's not.
Maybe it's...
Brazil!
-♪ ♪
-And I'm a sexy Brazilian boy
with a mullet
playing beach volleyball
with my even sexier friends
with even longer mullets,
and waxing all of the hair
off of our bodies
before we watch the "big game."
-Which is just (bleep) soccer.
-(laughter)
All the while chatting
about how great it is
that we "stayed"
in the Paris Climate Accord.
No!
(groans)
-(scattered applause)
-But...
Yeah, you... Yeah.
(applause)
Is this even America anymore?
Now I have to beg for claughter.
I can't even believe it.
The erosion of America doesn't
just stop at marriage. Oh, no.
Remember when people used to
give their babies normal names?
Like Donald and Eric
and Ivanka
and the other one.
Well, you could kiss
those days good-bye.
NEWSMAN:
The online media website Quartz
found neutral baby names
are pretty popular.
The name Charlie,
which a century ago
was almost exclusively
a name for boys,
but now 51% of all Charlies
are actually girls.
NEWSWOMAN: That's true.
It's a very cute name.
Oh, yeah. Charlie is
a cute name for boys.
It's Charlie's Angels,
not "Charlie's Charlies."
Genders are like
electrical outlets,
babies need them to learn.
(laughter)
Take my sons, Truck and Alito.
Every year, I give them both
a power tool,
a book of maps, and four seconds
of eye contact.
You know, stuff boys like.
We need gendered names so we
know which children are girls,
who have too many emotions,
and which children are boys,
who should suppress
all of those emotions.
I love you, Dad.
But is this what it's come to?
Is this even America?
-Or is this Malta?
-♪ ♪
Italy's Hawaii.
And I'm just sashaying down the
beautiful Mediterranean coast,
snacking on
13 centimeter-long Sargu,
listening to all
the Maltese people brag
about their female president,
who they elected in 2014.
Well guess what?
I'm not with her.
You hear that
Marie-Louise Coleiro Preca?
Ugh. Ugh.
And look, the kids aren't
all right.
Even the ones
who do have gendered names,
they're all wrapped up
in a dangerous new trend.
There's a new smoking trend
that's at a growing number
of high schools nationwide.
Yeah, this thing
is called JUULing.
TV REPORTER: The JUUL looks just
like a thumb drive.
You can actually plug it into
a computer to charge it.
And when you puff it,
you get a shot of nicotine,
just like a cigarette.
Now, students across America
are using them
in the classroom.
MATTHEW MYERS:
It is the sleekest, coolest
high-tech product
I have seen in a long time.
Oh, my man.
This guy knows sleek
and cool products.
Just last year, he hipped me to
a pretty sweet TV-VCR combo.
But come on, kids.
Don't give in to peer pressure.
Just because this cool guy
is telling you that JUULing
is the thing to do, that doesn't
mean you have to do it.
I mean, if he drove
his 1983 Saturn off a bridge,
slowly, by mistake,
because he was a bit sleepy,
I mean, would you? No.
Be an individual.
This JUULing thing is
a terrifying trend.
Not because kids are getting
hooked on nicotine.
I don't give a shit
about that. No.
But whatever happened to good,
old-fashioned cigarettes?
I mean, these kids talk about
these JUUL devices
being small and discreet
like those are positives.
Kids, if no one
can see you're smoking,
how do we know you're cool?
When I was younger, the cool
kids were always pantsing nerds,
smoking cigs, and butt-chugging
Boone's Farm.
Now every teen in America
is voting, protesting,
and puffing on USB drives.
Nothing about this is cool,
or American.
Am I even in my country anymore?
-Or am I in New Zealand?
-(sheep bleats)
And I'm sipping Sauvignon Blanc
with my sheep,
gazing off into an ocean
that's completely free
from oil rigs because they just
banned offshore drilling.
Climate change
isn't the issue, guys.
Why don't you do something
about all those immigrant
hobbits flooding the border?
Chuck, Chuck, bring me back.
Tell me I'm still
in the country I love.
Is our favorite salad
still potato?
CHUCK: Followed by pasta, tuna,
and marshmallow.
Nice.
Do yoga studios have better
teacher-to-student ratios
-than public schools?
-CHUCK: And more books.
Nice.
Are there more podcasts
than people?
-CHUCK: I just started one.
-I'm not gonna listen.
But I am relieved.
Thanks, Chuck.
The fight continues.